Johnson and Johnson just got permission to use to,
to market their version of ketamine.
And right now,
uh,
the dose of Ketamine I had was,
is like $90 a,
they're going to sell it for $15,000.
That's,
that's the danger of it getting properly legalized.
And as you said,
turned into a successful business.
Oh,
that's terrible.
Yeah.
Now why is it so expensive?
Just so they can make money off of it.
Now this is the therapeutic dose of ketamine in some sort of a psychiatric sort
of circle.
Like what's the environment they're going to do it.
And so they want to have it very much controlled.
Um,
but it looks like they want to stop there.
The therapist's giving it in the study,
um,
in their own office.
I mean,
which is,
which is what's going on now and have it controlled under,
under,
um,
you know,
the universal hospitals sort of situation.
And that there is a very good,
um,
and it's not even underground cause I'm not sure even shorts,
it's not illegal here.
Right?
Ketamine,
I think it isn't illegal.
Um,
but there are therapists giving it out now.
And I,
I bought mine legally.
You know,
I think you can,
oh,
you bought it with a prescription real?
Yeah.
With the prescription in New York.
Oh,
maybe I'm wrong.
Is Ketamine legal?
Yeah.
Legal under prescription.
Maybe it's a schedule two drug or something along those lines.
I was going to get that.
Someone sent me the message about the $15,000 and what that fucking craziness.
Yeah.
90 to 15,000.
Which is far worse.
Far,
far more than the,
the,
you know the amount that Martin Shkreli,
um,
put up the price right.
And went to jail for yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
he's,
he's a Douche bag though.
It's easy to point at him.
And he now owns that Wu Tang clan album.
Yeah.
Well haven't we?
That someone's got it,
man.
He's in jail.
So I studies,
I saw he's still running as business from like a burner cell phone in jail.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Well,
what he saying is though,
what happened in the Wu Tang clan album?
Uh,
I thought it was in possession of the FBI in there,
it off or something.
Come on son.
That shit is hilarious.
That might be one of the most hilarious parts of that story.
The FBI owns the Wu Tang clan forbidden album.
How much did he pay?
Any like $1 million for it.
You paid a lot because it was up for auction.
I think this says you paid 2 million.
Wow.
You can never get that money back.
Especially if the track's got released.
But what a great marketing tool.
It's worth more than $2 million in marketing.
And I feel so pretend is not released.
He confirmed he paid 2 million for it.
Yeah,
but he's full of shit.
That's,
yeah,
I bet he did though.
I mean,
if I had a gas,
you know,
I mean,
how many wealthy people out there,
Wu Tang clan fans?
A lot.
Yeah.
Probably probably a healthy bid.
Healthy bidding war as of uh,
this is as if like a year ago,
the feds have it.
So I don't know if there's an update on that.
There's always,
I mean,
when it's an individual that's like him,
that's easy to,
it's easy to look at him disparagingly.
Like,
look at this guy.
He's a deck,
you know,
oh,
he wants to raise the money or raise the price of these drugs that can help
people.
Fuck him.
Let's go get them.
But if it's Johnson and Johnson,
it's like,
yeah.
First of all,
they make baby powder.
Yeah.
You know,
they're so respected.
It's such a common household name,
and then I'm calling it ketamine.
They're calling it s ketamine,
s ketamine.
Slightly different.
That sounds like a snail,
right?
It sounds like.
Yes.
Cargo.
And it's a nasal spray.
Oh,
Jesus.
Different.
That makes it,
but,
huh.
Well,
it's better than shooting it up because I know that a lot of people take it
intramuscularly.
Where are you?
Just Jab it into your thighs,
I believe.
Yeah.
This is,
the drug will only be given by accredited specialists who must monitor patients
for two hours after administration.
I don't think you can just get it.
Go home and,
oh,
that makes sense.
Because a,
I know Neal Brennan did it and he had some very good results from it.
I took that.
I've spoke to him a few times.
He's tried everything.
He's,
he's trying.
He's had a,
he's a fucking hilarious guy.
He's had some real depression problems though.
He has some very good relief from a magnetic therapy.
Yeah.
And if you seen the involuntary trembling thing,
he did as well.
No.
What's the video of that was that,
I have no idea in voluntary tremble and she's sitting there and like,
cause I'm in shoulder is just going.
But he,
they just shit,
it was great juice them up with something.
Nothing.
Just 10 just talking.
Oh,
so he just does it on purpose.
Yeah.
Oh this therapist in the night gets him to do it somehow and that helps him.
I you'd have to ask him.
I don't know why I watched the three Mike special thinking it was just another
company stand up.
Right.
I had no idea about that.
That Mike being the serious stuff.
Yeah.
I thought it was incredible.
I thought it was a brilliant guy.
Very smart guy in his standup is outstanding and the kid just keeps getting
better.
But you know,
he's a guy fighting demons.
Yeah.
He's the classic case of the comedian that can never be held happy unless he's
on stage killing,
you know,
and then,
even then that's brief.
Like he's just never this jovial,
funny guy,
but he's a brilliant comedian.
Yeah.
But as long as I've known him for many years,
he struggled.
And it sounds like he's kind of an unofficial executive producer for a bunch of
other comedians as well.
Um,
how so?
Like advising them and giving them notes and it seems like a whole bunch of
people,
I'm sure he does doesn't and get his input.
People definitely respect him.
But yeah,
I'm sure he gives people tag lines and gives them advice and stuff like that.
Very smart guy.
But to be as honest as he was and,
and not even end it with a joke.
Right.
You know,
just to tell a serious story then.
Yeah,
that blew me away.
Yeah.
I met him on the Friday night and watched it on the Saturday morning and had no
idea and it was,
it was one of the best things I've seen for a long time.
Wow.
Yeah.
Now he's a special guy.
It's,
uh,
it's hard when,
you know,
I've had a few friends take their life three in the last year.
Um,
and you know,
you,
you see a guy like Neil and you know,
he's constantly pursuing all these different therapies and constantly trying to
find something that alleviates this depression and you just keep hoping you keep
opening,
you keep searching and keep hoping that one of these things sticks wise things
really see.
I mean he's very,
very proactive.
He's always searching for new things and very open about it and talking about
it.
But the ketamine does seem to have helped him quite a bit.
And he was telling me like,
man,
he's like,
this is so fucking crazy.
I'm going to this doctor's office and having these full blown psychedelic
experiences at the doctor's office.
Yeah.
When two hours later you're out on the street feeling completely normal,
what was your ketamine experience like?
Uh,
I took a tablet.
You put it under your tongue and let it dissolve for,
for 10 minutes.
And then I laid on the Sofa in a therapist office for two hours and I was out on
the street again two hours later.
So how long did it take before it kicked in?
And I don't really know cause I never thought it was kicking in.
Um,
but then I just found myself saying things and concluding things that I wouldn't
normally say.
And for the next week and a half I just felt like that was just a weight off.
Did you have any sort of a hallucinogenic experience?
No.
None whatsoever.
No hallucinating though.
Not Listen to listen to music.
Quite quietly put,
put an I,
I,
you know,
I must go on for a few minutes here and there.
Sometimes it didn't talk a tool.
Um,
but yeah,
just there was just this relief,
especially afterwards,
like in the week and a half or so off switch just felt this,
just this lightness.
And you know,
to your point about Neil being so open to trying everything,
even that,
even taking that step is hard sometimes.
Even getting out of the door sure is hard,
let alone researching this stuff and trying everything.
And when I first moved to America,
I said,
okay,
you're not going to do yoga.
You're not going to do therapy.
You're not gonna get prescription drugs.
That's in New York.
Bullshit.
Not to drop that skepticism and to,
to try everything.
You can be genuinely open to everything.
That's,
that's,
that's a lot in itself.